let's get more now on events in the
Commons labor MP Chris Bryan posted a
picture online of the tents scenes he is
with us now hi Mr bright thanks for
joining us tell us what happened
so as you know in the House of Commons
we vote by walking through a division
Lobby there's an eye Lobby and a no
Lobby and there's an entrance to each at
the main entrance to the no Lobby which
is where government members members of
the conservative party have been told
um by the Prime Minister well by the
deputy chief whip that they had to vote
through that door that you can just see
in that photograph
um uh and if they didn't they would lose
the whip they would no longer be
conservative MPS and I guess therefore
not be able to stand in the next general
election would lose their seats and so
on and they'd been told that earlier in
the day but then for 10 minutes before
the vote they were told oh no that
didn't apply anymore it wasn't a
confidence vote anymore so all these
people were gathering around completely
confused lots of Tory MPS very anxious
they they don't they wanted to vote
against fracking so with the labor party
because that's what the manifesto
commitment was in the last general
election but they didn't want to lose
the whip
um so they were very confused and you
can see that there's about 15 or 20
um mostly Tory MPS surrounding a couple
of story MPS who were waivers there was
a lot of shouting there was a lot of
gesticulating pointing at people
um jabbing at people and standing up to
it squaring up to people is how one
other MP described it to me and then in
in a moment that the only image I can uh
sum it up which sort of explains how it
then felt was that um the
you remember in the Royal Funeral when
um the Royal Naval ratings were marching
in lockstep together and just all moved
forward without you ever being able to
spot that anybody was pulling the gun
Carriage well that's what it felt like
um so that basically one I think or
maybe two MPS I couldn't see I was 15
yards away and were effectively sort of
frog marched through into the division
Lobby now okay as you know I've been
around a very long time in Parliament
and I'm not naive
um of course it's perfectly legitimate
for the whips to try and persuade
um their members uh by force of Reason
um to vote with them but it's not on to
intimidate and Bully and and in the last
few years we've really tried to change
the culture in Parliament around
bullying and one of the key things is
you're meant to recognize that the power
you have as an MP or as a senior MP and
if lots of you are standing around one
MP that is bullying and intimidation it
wouldn't be countenanced in any other
work workplace especially if you've got
the deputy chief executive as it were
the the Deputy Prime Minister and
another very senior member who who
incidentally were giving completely
different advice on as to whether or not
it was a confidence vote that is
bullying and in any other set workplace
it wouldn't be allowed and it should be
called out in Parliament I've heard Tory
MP say to me oh no honestly it was just
a full and Frank exchange of views I'm
sorry that is code for bullying and
people in Parliament need to understand
that that is bullying these days and it
needs to stop because otherwise the
behavior that happens there in the
chamber which is sanctioned by people in
this way ends up being the behavior that
they adopt towards their staff to other
staff in the building and that's the
culture that we've got to change in
Parliament and I should just say all of
this is happening it really heightened
emotions because of one simple reason we
haven't really had a government for nine
months now the Tory party has been
rallying about who should be its leader
first of all ousting Boris Johnson I
think quite rightly but nonetheless
ousting him and and then not going
forward with the general election but
electing a new party leader who
everybody knew would would end up being
pretty uh weak and in hot to different
factions within the conservative party
and yesterday you just saw a complete
and utter chaos and in that moment of
chaos there will be individual Tory MPS
who went to bed crying I know because
they've told me so
was there any manhandling that you saw
so um there's another photograph which I
didn't take um which shows a somebody
laying hands on on on another member
um but but as I say that the bit that
for me is the man handling it's not
picking somebody up and throwing them
through the door it's not it's not
aggressively pushing them but it's
certainly making sure that they went
through in an intimidatory way squaring
up and then the whole sort of team of
them sort of moving through uh so I I
would call that manhandling
um but it's not I I I'm not trying to
suggest that it's somebody dragging
somebody through other MPS who were
there
um I've spoken to I think now five
different other MPS both conservative
and labor who describe very similar
things
yeah I mean the reason I'm pressing you
on that uh Mr Bryant is because if you
if you put your hands on somebody else
and that's assault and then that's
something that the police should get
involved with
uh well yes I mean there's there's
photographic evidence
um obviously um what happens in the
chamber is I think now already going to
be investigated by
um Mr Speaker but but I make this bigger
Point even if there's no touching
um it was profoundly intimidatory it was
meant to be intimidating
um and uh and I you know I'm the chair
of the committee on standards we've been
trying to change the whole
um uh sort of culture in Parliament and
if at moments like these when emotions
are really high and we let ourselves
down I think we let the whole of
parliament down and incidentally I would
just say that
I represent one of the poorest
constituencies in the country in the
Rwanda
um yesterday we had news that inflation
is running at 10.1 percent probably
higher on food maybe 15 and with lots of
people have are either on uh benefits on
universal credit for instance but but in
work
um lots of people on very um depressed
incomes because there's been a wage
freeze for such a long time and that's
what voters think we should be dealing
with
um not having you know
Schoolboy Rouse in division obviously I
mean that's what to me I remember seeing
scenes like that when I was at school
and it was horrible then
and it's the same kind of people doing
it all over again
um Rhys MOG um Jacob reese-mogg has
apparently there are videos uh of that
labor MPS have taken of events he said
if there are show them to him have you
seen any
I haven't seen any videos I've only seen
still photos but um Jacob reesbog is in
all of them
um but look I mean the real problem for
the MPS was right at the top of
government they hadn't made a decision
as to whether it was a vote of
confidence or not so they're being early
in the day they were told by the deputy
chief whip that it was then the
government Minister stands up in the
chamber which is normally the definitive
moment 10 minutes before the vote and
says this isn't a vote of confidence and
then 10 minutes later and they're being
told all over again it is a motion of uh
of confidence and and that chaos I mean
it goes right to the prime minister to
Downing Street
yeah we don't have a com we don't have a
government we you might as well have I
mean the lettuce might as well be
running the country or the tofu
um you took a photograph which is
against the rules um it is how do you
defend that
um I I you you're quite right it's it's
um it breaches House of Commons
etiquette to take photographs
um however I think that in extraordinary
moments when you see what you consider
to be bullying and you know that
everybody will lie about it afterwards I
think it's important sometimes
um to to do that in the in the wider
public interest
and I I've told Mr Speaker already that
I did it
um and he knows about it
well I think it's a
whole in I know it
much indeed for joining us this morning
thank you